[Musique]
bienvenue dans le grand studio du figaro
on est en direct on est avec vous c'est
figaro live et et on attend vos points
de vue croyez vous qu emmanuel macron va
se montrer réellement plus ferme
réellement plus strictes en matière
d'expulsions d'étrangers clandestins on
vous pose la question sur twitter après
la réunion tenue hier par le chef de
l'état il a selon l'elysée dit à
plusieurs ministres d'être plus ferme
on y revient ce soir avec vous on y
revient avec vincent trémolet de villers
directeur adjoint de la rédaction du
figaro bonsoir dans ce format sans et
avec laurent joffrin ancien patron de
libération et leader des engagés de
passionnés de politique de passionnés de
foot aussi
et une fois n'est pas coutume on parlera
sport ce soir et plus exactement du cac
didier deschamps est il un modèle à
suivre un modèle gagnant bien sûr
question subsidiaire
la france va-t-elle gagné l'euro de foot
ça c'est la question qu'on pose sur le
site du figaro depuis la mi-journée pour
l'instant vous êtes sceptique
moi je partage pas votre point de vue
mais on y reviendra en deuxième partie
nous avons un problème d'éloignement
notre système est très difficile à
activer pour des raisons politiques
diplomatiques et médiatiques
il faut activer de manière volontariste
les dispositifs en vigueur voir quelques
phrases qui a déclaré emmanuel macron
hier lors d'une réunion exceptionnelle
avec les ministres concernés les
ministres concernés par quoi il vient
par la problématique de l'expulsion des
étrangers clandestins
les ministres concernés qui étaient
notamment présents la justice eric
dupond-moretti l'intérieur gérald
darmanin et les affaires étrangères jean
yves le drian question dès lors qu'on
vous pose sur twitter
emmanuel macron va-t-il se montrer
réellement plus strictes dans la
politique d'expulsion des étrangers
irréguliers
à droite le vice-président l air de la
région ile-de-france en doute
voici pourquoi
ça me paraît quand même une stratégie
électorale qui ne témoigne pas à mon
sens d'une grande sincérité sur la
nécessité qu'il y ait aujourd'hui une
immigration qui soient contrôlés je vais
pas vous dire que la politique
migratoire du gouvernement est mauvaise
il n'y en a pas il n'y a pas de
politique migratoire aujourd'hui je ne
sais pas moi aujourd'hui ce qui fait que
les âges lolette la responsabilité de se
taire moi je souhaite qu' une politique
migratoire équilibré où effectivement
immigration économique dont on peut
avoir besoin avec des quotas qui sont
votées au parlement on sait où on va et
surtout une lutte contre l'immigration
irrégulière qui aujourd'hui n'a
absolument pas au rendez vous vincent
très voilé est ce que votre menace trop
à raison ou à tout le moins comment on
interprétait le fait que emmanuel macron
et l'elysée ont cherché à faire savoir
qu'il y avait eu cette réunion alors il
ya un avis a deux explications la
première si on se retire de la tension
politique il ya des faits et il ya des
faits qui sont pas de temps qui est que
l'expulsion des étrangers en situation
régulière depuis pas depuis le camp
keddad emmanuel macron mais depuis
maintenant des décennies n'est pas
appliquée ou appliquer un pourcentage
extrêmement faible je n'ai pas le
chiffre on va voir la chelsea ions tout
à l'heure mais est ce que donnait en
dessous de 20%
donc c'est un fait et donc ce sujet
qu'il n'intéressait pas emmanuel macron
avant qu'ils prennent le pouvoir fait
partie des sujets françois hollande en
avait été la preuve aussi qui quand il
remonte quand vous pratiquer l'exercice
du pouvoir deviennent des sujets
concrets avec une cote des conséquences
pratiques et avec des conséquences
désastreuses pourquoi parce que le droit
d'asile dès lors ne devient plus la
grandeur du pays qui accueille mais
l'expression l'habillage d'une faiblesse
ou au fait on n'accueille pas puisque
quand on ne veut pas accueillir et quand
on veut expulser on ne fait pas donc ça
c'est je pense qu'il ne faut pas enlever
la part de
de deux volontés ça sert dans dance est
dans cette expression derrière il ya
évidemment une intention politique qui
est de montrer sur ce sujet sur lequel
emmanuel macron est en retard par
rapport à l'opinion est en tout cas par
rapport à l'est à une partie de
l'électorat de droite qu'il aimerait
séduire et donc de montrer qu'il a pris
conscience
ça fait partie de tout le portrait
l'autoportrait qu'il est en train
d'établir depuis quelques quelques jours
des racines et des ailes quand il va
dans le lot où il est comme l'espèce de
patrick de carolis devant les paysages
l'enracinement l'interview dans un digg
et la question migratoire et la question
de la frontière qui qui n'existaient pas
ou en tout cas qui dans son premier
imaginaire était quelque chose de sinon
de détestable au moins à enjamber la
devient quelque chose d'important donc
il ya à mon avis une prise de conscience
réelle et une intention de séduction
politique ensuite pour répondre à votre
question est ce qu'il va l'appliquer ça
on va en parler après que peut-être
laurent et ai répondu c'est au ministre
de l'intérieur de le faire mais pour le
moment pratiquement ce n'est pas
appliquée pour l'instant ça n'est pas
appliquer effectivement laurent on est
loin du compte
justement on a les chiffres en tous les
cas ceux qui sont donnés par l'elysée
cent vingt mille demandeurs d'asile par
an 20 mille obtienne le statut de
réfugié vingt mille repartent et entre
les deux 80000 qui n'obtiennent pas le
statut qui devrait repartir se
maintiennent sur le territoire le bleu
les déclarations de ma france de mâcon
c'est un geste politique
c'est lié au scrutin des régionales et à
la préparation de la présidentielle
parce qu'il comprend pourquoi parce
qu'il ya une parce que sa popularité
remonte en ce moment donc oui mais il
veut consolider sa
le loupé un qui fait sur l'électorat de
droite
c'est à son but il pense que la gauche
c'est très difficilement récupérable
dans la mesure où il a mené une
politique qui l'a qu'il a plutôt porté
sur certains points en tout cas et donc
c'est du côté de la droite qui a des
réserves pour en marché donc il fait des
gestes plutôt de droite
c'est typiquement un geste parce qu'il
n'y a pas deux il ya pas dans les formes
législative n'est de structures dans
cette déclaration il s'agit d'appliquer
mieux ou plus les règles existantes donc
ce n'est pas non plus c'est pas
révolutionnaire et donc voilà il se
droitise depuis le début et là c'est un
geste supplémentaire sur le fond moi je
suis favorable à ce qu'on applique les
lois alors c'est un fait que cette loi
là est mal appliquée quand on connait
pas appliqué à 80% à 90%
elle est mal appliquée c'est ce que je
dis souvent à mes amis de gauche c'est
que si on trouve que cette loi est
mauvaise il faut la changer mais si
vivant si on la change pas il faut
l'appliquer
comment ça laisse entendre à l'opinion
que que c'est la porte ouverte à l'excès
donc vous êtes favorable à ce qui a été
dit lors de cette réunion notamment sur
les tests pcr pour les clandestins
la france ne veut pas les faire au
départ deux essais mais mais mais à leur
arrivée sur le sol est notamment dit ou
bien il veut des mesures plus drastiques
avec l'algérie ça vous êtes favorable
pour les négociations avec les pays
d'origine pour qu'ils reprennent les
gens qui n'ont pas lieu de rester en
france
tous les gouvernements le fond mais
c'est là où il ya une part de démagogie
le nom parce que le
autant il faut appliquer la loire autant
quand on se plonge dans le concret du
dossier c'est très difficile
vous avez un ressorti stable ça pas très
bien de quel pays il est vous les bons
et marocains et puis le maroc n'en veut
pas qu'est ce que vous faites c'est
jeter à la mer donc vous êtes obligés de
garder plus ou moins c'est compliqué et
par ailleurs est-ce qu'il faut donner
aux forces de police comme objectif
principal la chasse aux clandestins ou
sans papiers parce que ça dépend du
jugement global qu'on porte sur les
migrations moi je suis de l'avis de
rocca c'est à dire on peut pas prendre
toute la misère du monde mais il faut en
prendre sa part donc il faut en prendre
une part et est donc y compris de gens
qui sont arrivés comme sans papiers et
dont on sait très bien qu'une partie
sont régularisés ou de quelques années
pour la raison qu'ils ont trouvé un
travail qui sont intégrés ou insérés en
tout cas dans la société française
d'ailleurs on arrive donc sur les 80000
par exemple qui ne sont pas reconduits
et chaque année non mais ils ont
vocation légalement à être reconduits et
puis au fond est très clair donc donc
court combat qu'on met un peu plus de
moyens et qu'on négocie avec les pays
d'origine pour que ça se fasse
moi je mets pas contre mais je constate
que ça passait pas pour vous titiller
bien marion ici au figaro je constate
que les gens qui gardent l'immeuble ils
sont manifestement ils sont pas
forcément de commander dans des sites
d'extrême droite des français de souche
que société française a besoin d'une
certaine manière de gens qui viennent de
l'étranger alors que ceux là sont
j'imagine qu'ils sont des papiers on
miserait pas tu es en pluie
enfin souvent les gens qui ont des
papiers ils n'en avaient pas osé quand
ils sont arrivés donc ils ont été
régularisés et dans tous les immeubles
parisiens
tous les immeubles de bureaux de paris
si vous y allez le matin à 5 heures du
matin les gens qui font le ménage et qui
assure un environnement de travail
correctes pour les salariés en général
ils viennent plutôt que dans la rue même
un problème comment c'est quand même un
problème dans le fait que de prendre
utilise quand on emploie ces gens là non
ce que je veux dire c'est que
le fait que y est on va prendre un
exemple qui se trouve que moi je dorme
chez moi sur mon vélo et donc je vois et
notamment quand les villes et
restaurants étaient fermés je voyais ils
voient les livreurs et vous avez là une
manoeuvre très très bas coût dans le pti
qui est utilisé en général qui n'a pas
le pied qui est utilisé en étant payés
une misère et qui installe une forme de
nouveau prolétariat qui à mon avis aura
des conséquences et social
et puis même sur plan moral qui sont
prêts mais il ya des efforts qui sont
faits pour leur donner un statut mais
sont tout à fait discutable mais ensuite
pour revenir à ce que vous disiez moi je
crois même pas que c'est pour séduire la
droit face et pour séduire la droite
mais il me semble qu'un candidat la
présence de république aujourd'hui ne
peut pas ne pas avoir un lien filaire
migrer sur l'immigration
c'est à dire est que c'est si on dit
souvent la bataille des idées qui a
gagné en sais rien mais il est certain
que sur le sujet de l'immigration et de
la sécurité
l'impatience de l'opinion publique et
des catégories populaires est remontée
jusqu'au sommet et donc maintenant ville
est visée d'ailleurs communiqué aurélie
le maillot hormis jean luc mélenchon il
n'y a pas un candidat qui disent il faut
régulariser tous les sans papiers mais
on en n'a pas or il y avait des gens le
parti socialiste qui le disaient ils
avaient fait je vais d'ailleurs les
frais enfin il a fait cent mille mais ce
disque ce discours-là a disparu
montebourg apparaît maintenant d'un jour
à l'autre d'une tribune et interviews en
tenant des propos assez sévère aux
signaux sociaux sur ce sujet là donc oui
je crois
il me semble que sur ces deux sujets
immigration sécurité on pourrait ajouter
laïcité ou le rapport à l'islam
politique
il ya une forme de consensus qui va très
au delà de la droite qui qui doit
représenter peut-être en une fois nand
et 70% de le dessus ce qu'on parle de
l'école puisqu'on parle de l'immigration
le consensus
ça dépend avec qui on parle si on parle
de une partie de la droite et l'extrême
droite en une duration s'il n'y a pas
consensus
le
la position du racing en national est
totalement démago designs immigration
zéro
ils font cela il faudrait introduire un
espèce d'état policier
il faut fermer complètement les
frontières vous ferra mur immigration
zéro il faut un mur et on l'a vu aux
etats-unis que ce n'est pas son nom
propre départ et donc ayant plus je suis
contre le principe de mettre un mur dans
les alpes
les rouges de 16 ou ou entre la france
et la belgique c'est absurde c'est qu'il
rate joueurs pardon je vous coupe sur sa
wii sa seule chose qu'on attend souvent
mais quand giscard qui n'était pas
extrêmement à un peu arrêter
l'immigration dans les années 70 avant
le regroupement familial il à arrêter
purement et simplement comment est
simplement l'immigration et à ce moment
là on s'est dit bon on peut plus faire
venir de main d'oeuvre immigrée
donc comment moi je suis favorable à ce
qu'il y ait une règle problème wallon à
une position de principe toute la gauche
m
à part une frange plus quand on n'a plus
droit de l'hommiste ou plus comment dire
généreuse éventuellement mais plupart
des responsables des gens qui veulent
gouverner 10
il faut réguler l'immigration après cela
il faut savoir ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire que sur le plan de
l'immigration légale ya à peu près 200
mille personnes qui rentrent c'est
difficilement compressible parce qu'il
ya les étudiants refuser les étudiants
étrangers
il ya le regroupement familial il ya des
règles européennes moi je suis pour
qu'on les respecte et il ya les réfugiés
réfugiés sont des gens qui sont menacés
physiquement chez eux alors ils auraient
ces gens là à mon avis il faut les
prendre mais il faut pas aller au delà
c'est à dire que vous avez cent
cinquante mille deux cent mille
personnes qui rentreront chaque année
moi je suis favorable à ce qu'on dit ça
on n'en font pas plus que ça et et
deuxièmement il ya un problème d'accueil
parce que l'immigration si elle est
anarchique ça marche très mal évidemment
si si les gens entre ce sens qu'on lui
contrôler un tant soit peu sans qu'on
sache s'ils parlent la langue ou pas
s'ils sont moins vaguement intégré ou
pas s'ils ont les attaches s'ils ont un
travail où ils n'ont pas de travail et
où ils vont habiter où ils vont habiter
dans le point central mon avis parce que
comme ils se regroupent par affinités
souvent ou simplement à cause du prix
des loyers dans les cités qu'on connaît
ça ne cesse de
poser des problèmes sociaux ou et de
cohabitation et donc il faut les
répartir est ce que je dis là c'est une
politique c'est à dire ça consiste à
dire on va assigner chacun des gens qui
rentrent en france on vous dit vous
allez à tel endroit parce que là il ya
du besoin de main d'oeuvre éventuels ou
vous créerez ventura votre main d'oeuvre
votre emploi vous même si vous faites un
business quelconque mais il ya de la
place et il n'y a pas de conservation
préexistantes
c'est ce qu'on fait en allemagne cette
politique que je décris ce n'est pas une
un projet en l'air c'est le système
allemand
je pense que ça marche mieux et on le
sait bien parce que quand on a quand on
a démantelé le ce qu'on appelle la
jungle ou d'aller oui ça c'est 15 9 quel
effet ça il a réparti
c'était un nombre limité de gens quand
ils étaient tous ensemble la galette et
il les a répartis dans les villes les
villages de france
depuis on entend plus parler oui il
laisse entendre que ça a marché
je suis si ça marchait bah oui entendu
parler c'est à dire que ce le phénomène
auquel on assiste aussi c'est que
l'immigration qui était un problème de
métropole jusqu'à il ya peu a jusqu'à ya
dix ans le un certain nombre de deux
provinces ne connaissait pas la question
migratoire et les problèmes afin
d'ancrer est aujourd'hui alors certains
les voient encore à la télévision mais
c'est une étude qui avait fait des ronds
pour quelqu'un qui montrent que même
dans les toutes petites villes il ya
maintenant la possibilité d'une
ghettoïsation du fait de populations
immigrées qui habitent dans les mêmes
quartiers et qu'ils peuvent pour
certaines d'entre elles de montrer des
moeurs un peu en dissidence avec ceux
avec qui vivent bon merci paul le guen
parle de moi je connais bien je tâche à
granville
vraiment il ya très peu de gens votent
contre l'immigration quand même être un
peu où ceux qui sont là ils en bouleau
et puis il invite dans les hlm
oui mais il y en a qui d'abord on
ont des relations des expériences y en a
qui ont quitté aussi les périphéries
tout le travail que qu'à montrer
christophe lui simplement ce que je veux
dire c'est que ce le saupoudrage auquel
s'est livré 15 9 et que défendent est
aussi manuel valls et qui est défendue
par certains la question c'est la
possibilité d'accueil et la phrase de
rocard que vous rappeliez moi je pense
qu'on arrivait à saturation
c'est à dire que de tout ça la saison de
laisser comme ça rejoint ce que dit
emmanuel macron c'est à dire que de
toute façon quand bien même vous auriez
raison l'opinion publique considère que
l'urgence est d'essayer d'intégrer le
mieux possible les immigrés qui sont là
mais qu'il devient de plus difficile de
plus en plus difficile
acceptez-vous fayard est-ce qu'il faut
les accueillir et non mais je ne dis pas
qu'il faut pas fuir personne mais mais
mais mais mais alors d'accord coller un
mouvement famille là bas je pensais y
soient respectés c'est un laurent entre
les émigrés question il ya quand même
une part dont parisien il ya quand même
une réalité humaine
la plupart des gens qui viennent ils
viennent pour travailler bien de papa
ils viennent parce que ils cherchent
leur place au soleil
ce sont des braves gens non on va
prendre preuve d'ailleurs c'est qu'ils
sont embauchés ils sont employés partout
on va prendre une autre réalité humaine
qui à mon avis aussi entraîner les
propos de macron et qui obsède le
ministère de l'intérieur a juste dit en
rappelant les mineurs isolés
oui mineurs isolés qui en général ne
sont pas mineurs qui ne sont pas isolés
mais qu'ils ne viennent pas pour
travailler parce que le plus souvent les
pauvres ils sont la proie de groupes
organisés qui sont là oui ça ça mais
répliqué et semer la terreur ça existe
oui mais ça c'est quand même le fait de
la faiblesse de la structure étatique
qui fait que ces gens là d'abord rentrer
assez facilement et ensuite qu'on ne
sait pas quoi en faire et ça dans
l'opinion à granville comme à la
courneuve s'est intégrée et donc
peut-être on va conclure là dessus c'est
que comme il n'ya pas de politique
d'immigration très très affichée est
très très appliqué le réflexe
aujourd'hui et encore une fois c'est les
enquêtes d'opinion qui le monde quand
vous trouvez trouve où il ya trop
d'immigration en france
oui est-ce qu'il faut la réduire le plus
possible oui et on est au dessus des 59
cents enfin moi je la défends une
position différente oui c'est une
politique ni que je défends est une
politique alors nous la contester on
peut dire que c'est beaucoup trop
laxistes ou je ne sais quoi d'accord
mais enfin c est une politique vous
permettrait peut-être avant de conclure
qu ont convenu avec les internes avec
les internautes justement qui eux sont
extrêmement sceptique sur 20 tandis qu'à
ceux qui s'expriment et ceux qui nous
remonte sur les intentions de d'émana
macron puisque la question qu'on pose
sur twitter c'est si manuellement macron
va se montrer donc réellement plus
strictes dans la politique d'expulsion
des étrangers irréguliers et vous
répondez non à 75 % ce qui est plus que
au début de l'émission
kriss kross c'est que du pipeau tout ça
à la proche des élections c'est
électoraliste estime nicole en attend
les actes pour une fois bernard c'est
juste une manoeuvre cousue de fil blanc
pour faire du le pen essayé de lui
piquer des voix
babineau l'immigration est un des angles
morts du quinquennat d'emmanuel macron
il n'est pas à l'aise et des échéances
électorales approchent on aborde
toujours des sujets complexes et lourd à
la fin du quinquennat ce n'est pas
sérieux on a l'impression estime flight
qu'il est impossible d'expulser les
étrangers à cause de la complexité
administrative de notre pays et c'est ce
qu'a justement souligné
macron le chef de l'état pendant la la
réunion
en tous les cas d'après ce que raconte
l'elysée ce qui est intéressant dans ce
qui remonte quand même de la part des
internautes c'est qu'il ya vraiment un
vrai scepticisme par rapport à
l'intention mais je vais à londres et
même affair pas le défenseur mais enfin
petit l'avocat de même de françois
hollande
je pense qu'il faut pas confondre deux
choses il ya la volonté politique et le
courage qui fait que l'on neuf qu'on
l'on parvient à faire appliquer des
choses difficiles en l'occurrence la loi
dans l'expulsion des étrangers en
situation irrégulière
ensuite il ya la tactique politique
consiste à dire chose pour avoir des
voix mais il ya quand même
entre les deux une comment dire un souci
du bien commun qui fait que je quand
emmanuel macron quand françois hollande
confie ada vélum ce qu'il faut éviter
c'est la partition donc ça veut dire une
prise de conscience très profonde de la
question migratoire puisqu'il parle de
partition le président la république
socialiste à l'époque
et quand emmanuel macron dit ça il
souhaiterait que ça se passe
après ils ont pas le courage la volonté
la constance
les équipes la cohérence avec leur
doctrine précédente
mais je ne crois pas que ce soit des
signes profond qui se disent il n'y a
pas de problème tout le monde rentre et
puis je vais faire quelques discours
pour faire croire le contraire je ne
crois pas du tout mais même cette idée
selon laquelle un monde comme on veut et
fausse et je voudrais citer simplement
le livre de maxime tandonnet qui était
conseiller à l'immigration sous nicolas
sarkozy donc avec un président de la
république s'était fait élire là dessus
qu'ils avaient une volonté de faire des
choses étant donnée était chargé de ça
et il raconte me sellini s'appelle au
coeur du pouvoir et y montre
l'extraordinaire difficulté à faire
appliquer jusqu'au bout de la chaîne le
discours le plus éloquent et le plus
éclatant qui est prononcé à l'elysée et
que à chaque étape
ça bloque donc c'est ça le l'attention
elle est là la question c'est la
réalisation et c'est le problème de
l'es17 internautes c'est on a
l'impression qu'il est impossible
d'expulser les étrangers à cause de la
complexité totalement impossible ou
l'inversé rien à 85 dans bien mais ça
rejoint et au fait c'est à mon avis le
vrai problème un des problèmes qui va
être le central pendant l'élection 2022
c'est c'est même pas l'efficacité c'est
la légitimité du politique c'est à dire
est ce qu'il est capable d'appliquer ce
qu'il dit voilà c'est tout et aider les
lois existantes pas l'orgie législatives
elle vous a su lancer dans la brousse en
polémiquant quand il ya des hommes ou
femmes politiques qui disent il faut
aboutir à l'immigration zéro
ce sont les démagogues ça ne marchera
pas d'abord je suis content sur le
principe c'est une chose mais ça c'est
ma position est intéressant c'est que ça
ne marche pas c'est pas possible il faut
accepter une part des migrations après
il faut l'organiser
c'est que vous n'aurez collective ya
deux politiques de migration est dit
laurent aussi à faire des promesses
qu'ils ne sont
consiste à dire il y aura plus
d'immigration il ya de l'autre côté une
politique qui dit oui il faut les
limites et il faut l'organiser ce que
vous dites sur l'immigration faut
accepter c'est une immigration qui est
de l'ordre assez finalement à ses
marques
20 c'est marqué dans le temps c'est à
dire que vous laissez des étudiants sont
pas forcément des gens qui ont vocation
à rester par exemple c'est l'immigration
sur le regroupement familial c'est
peut-être là où il ya un débat peut-être
dans l'est dans les années à venir là et
puis et puis des réfugiés ou sas a
toujours jugé impossible de remettre en
question le droit à droite à lyon non
mais le droit d'asile va mourir si comme
la loi comment la vie n'est pas noyé
wallace et on a répondu donc à la
question où vous êtes sceptique
vis-à-vis d intention d' emmanuel macron
je pense qu'on vous a répondu le débat
continue toute façon je pense qu'on va y
revenir
il ya un autre des bars là où vous êtes
sceptique alors là vous ça m'étonne plus
c'est sur les possibilités de gagner
pour l'équipe de france
l'euro 2020 qui devait donc se tenir
l'an dernier qui a été reportée pour
cause de pandémie cet après midi donc
emmanuel macron dont on parlait était à
clairefontaine chez les bleus et il a
répondu aux questions de nos confrères
bfm tv il a notamment rendu cet hommage
à didier deschamps
surtout il y avait chez lui je trouve
une vigilance sur tous les aspects je
crois que c'est ça qui est le plus
admirable c'est à dire évidemment sur
les schémas tactiques et les schémas de
jeu mais sur les individualités et la
manière de les faire grandir et donc je
crois que c'est ça qui force le respect
voilà et il est constamment vigilant à
tout cela donc c'est un très grand
sélectionneur je pense que c'est l'un
des évidements l'un des plus grands de
notre histoire est l'un des plus grands
aujourd'hui au monde
sur le fond vous êtes d'accord avec un
imac rond laurent joffrin oui je parle
ces spécialistes pour pour le contredire
de toute manière à les maîtriser dans
l'équipe de foot de sciences po avec
françois hollande
oui moi je fais quelques matchs de demi
gauche migolet vous aurez l epa l'époque
il y avait les intérêts made me prévost
lui lui est ailier droit à droite sur le
fond donc vous êtes d'accord avec
emmanuel macron sur sur la période
d'échangé sur des façons les
sélectionnés on le juge sur les
résultats sont très bons il ya forcément
une raison et va centrer volet de quoi
des champs ils n'ont selon saiem
plusieurs choses bluffante dont il ya
d'abord son ses résultats son palmarès
c'était un joueur extrêmement efficace
pas extraordinairement élégant donc il
ya il ya quelque chose d'admirable dans
le côté tâches ingrates travaille sans
cesse répétée faire des dizaines et des
dizaines de tacles pendant les matches
est moins visible que le joli passements
de jambes ou que que le beau dribble
corée fait zidane ou un autre donc il ya
cette image là mais moi ce qui me bluffe
depuis qu'il est entraîneur c'est qu'il
a quand même hérité d'une équipe qui
était dans un état je parle pas de la
qualité de jeu il y avait des très bons
joueurs mais dans un état de malaise
inouïe c'est à dire que l'équipe de
france était composée de gens qui se
détestaient entre eux et était détesté
par une partie du pays c'était quand
même quelque chose de ré est arrivé il a
récupéré cette image là sous une partie
du groupe et il est parvenu assez vite
quand même à restaurer une confiance en
fait une espèce de il y avait une
disposition de méfiance devoir de
défiance vis à vis de cette équipe et il
est parvenu à restaurer une confiance
dans l'opinion et là il y est même
parvenu avec l'événement qui a précédé
le les jours où nous sommes et qui a
marqué le
le foot qui est la sélection de benzema
ou j'avoue m'être trompé quand elle est
apparue quand on a su que benzema allait
dans l'équipe de france je me suis dit
est ce que je fais bien mon métier et
qu'il était tard le soir
j'ai dis à ceux qui étaient permanents
ciblons préparez vous parce que là ça va
devenir une polémique politique ça va
c'est on sait de quoi va être faite la
journée de demain et j'ai écouté la
conférence de presse en rentrant chez
moi de didier deschamps et j'ai entendu
un politique d'ailleurs et je me suis
dit bon d'accord le match est plié
client aura peu de polémique
il a réglé la question sert qu'il a
éteint les possibilités d'un an dit il a
parlé avec autorité sur le thème c'est
la clémence d'auguste qui a fait le con
je lui ai excuses mais c'est moi le
patron c'est pas lui donc je n'ai pas
cédé et j'ai sélectionné simplement un
bon joueur et donc voilà il a quand même
ce savoir-faire là qui est exceptionnel
dans le sens où les égos qui la gérait
sont quand même des gens qui sont adulés
qui est beaucoup mieux leur vie que lui
qui n'ont pas besoin de l'équipe de
france au fond pour faire des carrières
internationales fulgurante et donc qui
pourraient devenir des boudeur des
capricieux et donc il ya chez lui quand
même cette disposition là qui en plus du
joueur qu'il a été
montre une capacité d'autorité de
discernement et une vraie capacité de
meneur d'hommes à mon avis deschamps met
en avant le collectif dans une société
de plus en plus individualiste c'est ça
qui est rafraîchissant nous dit mme
babineau secoue la guinée aux arts est
partager le point de vue de babine au
sérieux ça prouve que la personnalité du
patron du responsable contre beaucoup à
changer de responsable unac où tout
allait mieux et ça prouve aussi qu'on
peut faire travailler ensemble des gens
très différents avec des origines
mélangé avec des contours disparates
qu'on va mettre les uns plus les pieds
en place à dire que ce malaise quand
l'équipe de france et a été déchirée
c'était quand même une question avait
des questions identitaires il y avait
des questions de bruit qui ont une
devise sont estompées appartenant une
religieuse d'origine de dallas comme lui
passe la balle ça s'est terminé
enfin peut-être s'exhibe dans l'arrière
salle on n'en sait rien montré sur le
terrain
non il ya un collectif il ya une unité
et chaque je pense à la ville sont
représentés par cette équipe sur sa
digue
j'ai été très clair dans son interview
au parisien dimanche où il a dit que son
attachement à la france à l'identité
française et que l'hymne national d'or
retentit c'est quand même tapé dans une
interview à l'ops
ou quand un autre joueur parle à une
télévision sans fait qu'il ya pas une
consigne mais un état d'esprit
la volonté d'installer un climat de
sérénité et de ne pas faire de cette
équipe un objet politique c'est quand
même c'était pas du tout du tout évident
c'était pas gagné maintenant on va voir
s'ils vont gagner moi ce que je crains
quand même c'est qu'ils sont dans la
position dans laquelle l est et l
allemagne quand j'étais jeune c'est à
dire les deux favoris l'équipe arrive
favori est bon mais ça prouve que quand
il ya un projet collectif et quelqu'un
pour l'incarner on peut unifier des gens
qui viennent d'horizons extrêmement
différents
c'est possible onze personnes 18 mai
mais en tout cas c'est le symbole du
fait que l'on arrive à faire c'est pas
black blanc beur cette mythologie qui
est passée un peu parce qu'après il y
beaucoup de difficultés mais c'est un
contre exemple de ce qu'on dit a en
permanence dans le débat public m'ont
dit vous savez les gens il n'aime pas
vivre ensemble conditions du ballet le
foot c'est pas comme ça mais juste et à
quoi vous attribuez à quoi vous
attribution fait qu'il projet collectif
et qui est une discipline non pas une
discipline militaire
mais une volonté commune de bien faire
de bien faire son travail
l'hémicycle et une indiscipline et c'est
une discipline consentis les gens
comprennent bien que d'une équipe il ya
des règles qui doit voir moi je n'ai
jamais rencontré mais il doit avoir une
autorité naturelle pour pouvoir parce
qu'il ya le problème et identité avions
parlé il ya le problème de
l'individualisme absolue qui se
développerait la milliardaire et vous
rentrez qui sont quand même des gens qui
normalement n'écoute personne d'autre
qu'eux mêmes et il parvient est encore
une fois sans montrer en apparence deux
choses éclatante pense que sur le
terrain il ne remonte pas dg ce que ne
savent pas faire mais bon il à sa
carrière il à sa connaissance et il a
certainement la capacité à imposer son
autorité sans avoir
à se montrer autoritarisme plus est ce
que son autorité ne tient pas du fait
également qu'il ait fait partie de la
team 98 de l'équipe de france qui a été
la première à gagner la coupe du monde
de foot
ce qui n'était pas le cas des précédents
entraîneurs oui mais ils femmes
maintenance la génération qu'il dirige a
gagné aussi
avant il était le les prestigieuses qui
était parvenu à maintenant il est quand
même face à une nouvelle génération qui
est championne du monde aussi qu'ils
gagnent tous dans tous les sens et qui
est favorite comme on n'a jamais était
favori donc ils parviennent encore alors
on va voir peut-être qu'ils vont le
sangler tous aient eu des petits
accrochages d'apparemment entre giroud
et autour du bape et mais mais mais pour
le moment
il arrive encore à insuffler dans un
monde de fric un peu de toc de star
system
les vertus du collectif du travail de
discrétion face et alors ce n'est pas
complètement ça on va pas non plus mais
c'est quand même moi je trouve ça assez
bluffant mais je pense que des joueurs
même individualistes et qui ont gagné
toutes sortes de choses qui ont un
talent hors du commun
ils savent bien qu'une équipe c'est pas
une addition de personnes c'est qu'une
équipe de foot il faut que il abat les
circule que les taxes tiens à répéter et
que des mouvements collectifs c'est la
plupart du temps sur des mouvements
collectifs pour faire l'avocat lui pour
faire l'avocat du diable
est ce que justement ça pas été
facilitée par le fait des échecs
précédents qui étaient justement due à
la zizanie zh à la zizanie à
l'individualisme et aux échecs à l'uimm
est consécutive à ça mais c'était très
difficile
c'est à dire que le l'équipe de france
était l'expression une des expressions
du malaise français que voilà et il ya
eu les mêmes phénomènes avant avec aimé
jacquet qui a été vilipendé par la
presse avant la coupe du monde qui a
fait preuve d'autorité et il avait un
palmarès inférieure inférieure when do
mais il avait une autorité drapeau
commun d'ailleurs aimé jacquet et didier
deschamps c'est qu'il n'était pas
flamboyant non plus
bah non c'est ça c'est à dire que on
sait pas ce que c'est la brigade légère
ou d'artagnan c'est plus le poilu de 14
des champs si on doit prendre des
métaphores mythe c'est à dire c'est on
subit on serre les dents tiens ne il
passe pas c'est pas l'armée
napoléonienne qui admire laurent joffrin
ou la charge de murs un mets donc c'est
moi c'est moins beau platini mais ils ce
sont des vertus qui sont complètement
contraire aux fêtes à à celle que
développe aujourd'hui le football de ce
système il ya un autre joueur qui a une
gueule au kanté qui incarne sa quête un
joueur qui court dans tous les sens qui
marque très peu qui est dans le
dévouement pour les autres membres de
l'équipe et qui est en train de prendre
d'ailleurs une
dans l'esprit des gens il devient la
figure aussi du jour qui se sacrifie
pour les autres un peu un espèce de
joueur exemplaire de deschamps d'après
deschamps quoi est ce que je vous
demande et c'était justement est-ce que
aimé jacquet comme didier deschamps ne
t'a pas n'étant pas l'image vraiment de
lentilles flamboyance donné que presque
voûté progrès mais jacques de toujours
le petit cahier et le survêt ce qui est
un peu pareil pour deschamps par rapport
à ces types flamboyant mais grosse
bagnole de rigaud cylindres etc a
justement est-ce que ce contraste n'a
pas et 7 cette posture là n'a pas
facilité non plus finalement bâlois
contrat jumale fille comme le président
normal enfin c'était l'entraînement
normal ça a marché mais mais au départ
figeac et des risques dans sa sélection
et quand il a annoncé sa sélection était
un reer université de deux 2 autres
points peut-être chez deschamps est ce
que c'est pas là aussi on n'a pas une
clé il dit justement ce qu'il est les
gens j'ai pas osé la faire essayer merci
dont je vais parler il faut toujours se
remettre en cause
puisqu'il dit le plus dur maintenant
c'est de conserver le leadership et donc
et pour lui la seule seule la victoire
importe c'est vrai dans tous les
portraits qu'il y assez le refus de
perdre la volonté la volonté
de gagner et est-ce que c'est pas aussi
justement une des ses clefs et là aussi
où il peut être un modèle à suivre dans
une ambiance où les entraîneurs se
disent il faut que je gagne quoi qu'il
arrive un peu à peu ouais enfin quel
entraîneur il y va on va faire on va
perdre en beauté ce formidable
willy l'aï là il est pas comme si
l'actuelle marée des chorales à tourner
le dos à la volontairement au génie
français d'être magnifique dans la
défaite et 2 et champion du monde deux
matches amicaux et on perd mais on
aurait dû gagner et c'était ma is heavy
82 enfin qu'ils veulent une mythologie
nationale
lui il a fait une haie cameron du
football et lui ai fait une équipe un
peu plus
une terne au départ avec un thé un
système de jeu qui était moins éclatants
mais qui gagne bon alors après il ya on
peut avoir des débats tard le soir pour
savoir si c'était justement parce qu'il
y avait au moins du romantisme noir et
moi j'aime bien le beau jeu mais il
vient de nantes à l'origine donc il est
il connaît le jeu à la nantaise
c'était le nec plus ultra il est touché
à tout est calme il dit que l'une de ses
nostalgies c'était quand même l'époque
il à l'époque il a un potentiel
politique je pense pas qu'il faut mais
enfin et il a du crédit pour cette
rentrée contre il a du crédit très au
delà du foot genève pensez vous que
l'équipe de france de football va gagner
l'euro c'est ça le pronostic qu'on
demande aujourd'hui voter oui moi sur le
site et moi aussi je vote je vote oui
jma moi aussi voilà on est toujours là
effectivement on est en minorité par
rapport à ce que vous dites et c'est ça
c'est intéressant c'est les vertus du
débat et chacun peut exposer son point
de vue merci beaucoup d'avoir partagé le
vôtre avec celui des internautes merci
de nous avoir également partagé le vôtre
on se retrouve demain même heure même
endroit
la une du figaro dans la une du figaro
demain c'est bayonne qui arrive en
europe est effectivement tous les enjeux
il enrôle et l'europe contre la chine de
cette première ville a fait son choix du
président américain sur le vieux
continent a on se retrouve demain même
heure même endroit sur figaro live at
reading
[Musique]